let's go to our caller from the 832 area
code who's calling today from 832
hi david is this me yes it is
all right uh thanks for thanks for
picking up my call and um
i know you're not a historian david but
this election to you you know
do you think it's just an unprecedented
election or do you see any similarities
between this election
you know any previous election you've
lifted war in history so
in terms of similarities i i'm less
clear
what i can tell you is it's the most
important election
i will be voting in and earlier in the
week i gave this example of you know in
2012 when barack obama had been in for
four years
we were in the middle of an economic
recovery mitt romney was was running
against barack obama and
he didn't really have a great case as to
why you should even really vote for him
and he's going to lower taxes for rich
people and he had some
you know different different ideas about
the direction he wanted to take health
care and
of course socially romney was much more
conservative
but i said leading up to that election
i believe barack obama is the better
candidate and i believe barack obama has
earned a second term
but it was not the most important
election in that most likely the economy
was going to probably do well between
2012
2013 and 2017 regardless of whether it
was romney or obama
this is a very different situation where
our ability to recover from four years
of trump
is dramatically uh more plausible than
recovering from eight years of donald
trump and so
in terms of its unprecedented nature
this is without a doubt the most
important election i will be voting in
interesting interesting and i'm guessing
that in
in 2016 that at the time that was the
most important election you'd be voting
but this has superseded what's crazy is
there was a large well let me let me
back up
there was a group of people on the left
who in 2016 was saying
this doesn't feel that important i mean
you know corporate
corporate corrupt hillary versus trump
i don't care if it's not going to be
bernie it doesn't make it
look at how consequential the 2016
election was
consider how different things would be
on the virus today if it had been
hillary clinton
rather than donald trump and so i
believe that
there were a lot of people who didn't
think 2016 was that important
in retrospect we know that that was very
very wrong
interesting yeah no i agree with that i
definitely agree and
yeah with with hillary i think the
approach to the virus would have been
probably the antithesis
and it would have been not about hillary
it would have been about doctors whereas
now it's all about trump and trump's
fights with doctors and etc
if it had been hillary it would have
been much less about fireworks it would
have been
we're having doctors run this we're
having doctors make decisions because
that's who should be doing it public
health officials
yeah yeah she would have been a good
administrator in the sense of delegating
tasks
yes yeah thanks for taking my call david
appreciate it thank you so much for the
call we're going to take a brief break
but if you're holding don't hang up
that's my advice because
i'm going to go right back to the phones
after this short break